And of course we're absolutely keenly
aware of that in the modern world because
we're possessed by this sense
that all of our frenetic activity,
all of our frenetic motivated activity
is producing alterations in the world
order such that nature itself is going
to be destroyed and eliminate us,
right?
That's classic Sumerian fear and
nothing's changed in the last 5,000 years.
The Sumerians presumed that once the
elder gods were constructed and started
moving around on the planet,
that their activity,
they're mindless activity.
Because remember,
these aren't well integrated
motivational forces.
They're more like primordial
beasts right there.
Unintegrated activity risks
plunging everything back and chaos.
Well tie match the
representative of chaos,
this generative chaos.
But so what the Sumerian say?
Well,
the elder gods because a lot of racket,
they move around the planet and they
upset time at and she decides that enough
is enough and she's
going to wipe them out.
So she's sitting at the
bottom of the ocean,
fuming away as the elder gods go about
their business and then they take one
step too many and they kill Appsu.
Who's her husband?
Now,
the Sumerian creation myth
doesn't say much about this,
but we know that Appsu is the male con
sort of chaos that makes it mortar.
So what happens is the elder
gods destroy order itself.
They destroy culture itself.
And as soon as you destroy culture,
all hell breaks loose.
And that's exactly what happens
in this scenario creation myth.
So Tye,
Maddie,
Mergis,
she's going to wipe everything out
and the world will revert back to its
primordial non-existence state.
Now the older guards get wind of this,
and of course they're just
terrified because they know
that this thing that gave
rise to them,
whatever it is,
the matrix of being can easily
wipe them out at a moment's notice.
And so despite the fact
that they're trans,
transpersonal,
and immortal,
and characterized by a certain amount
of power in the face of absolute chaos,
they're insufficient.